she said this fate is the ratio of um
who you are and who you want to be who
you want to be do do do you think
there's something to this whole
manifestation thing like focusing on a
vision of what you want the world to
become and in in that focusing you
manifest it like Pao said in The
Alchemist when you want something all
the universe conspires in helping you to
achieve it is there something to that I
think so yes and I always think of you
know what I do as this the culmination
of energy information and matter MH and
how to Direct Energy Information and
matter in the design of a thing or in
the design of a life I think living is
very much a a process of channeling
these energies to where they need to go
I think that the manifestation or part
of that manifestation is the pointing to
the Moon in order to get get to the moon
and and and that's why manifestation is
also directional it has that vector
quality to it that that I think of
agency as have you uh in your own life
has there been things you've done where
you kind of direct that energy
information and matter in a way that
opens up new possibilities yeah I mean
you've also said somewhere I'm probably
misquoting that uh you're you're you're
many things
you and AR are many things and you
become new things every 10 years or so
oh I did say that somewhere somewhere
that every decade you're sort of switch
that was an old that was a previous Nar
that said that yeah I I did say some
time ago that you have to sort of reboot
reboot every 10 years um to to keep
creative and keep inventive and and keep
fresh is there are things you've done in
your life where just kind of uh doors
opened I think everything everything uh
everything good I've found in my life
has been found in that way of
[Music]
um letting go and suspending my sense of
disbelief and often you will find me say
to the team suspend your disbelief I
don't care that this is impossible let's
assume it is where does it take us and
that suspension of disbelief is
absolutely part and parcel of the
creative
act um you
know I did so
when um I was in medical school I was in
hadasa and in the Hebrew
University and um I remember I left
medical school for architecture the day
my grandmother passed away and that was
a moment of relief and that was a m a
door that was closing that opened other
opportunities um but that of course
required letting go of the great vision
of becoming a doctor and letting go of
the dream of you know being surrounded
by wonderful patients and the science of
medicine and the research associated
with that science and letting go of that
dream uh to accomplish another
um and and it and it it has happened
throughout my life in in different ways
um MIT was another experience like that
where
people pointed at me as you know the
designer for whom the academic currency
is not necessarily the citation index
and of course in order to get tenure at
MIT you have to look at the citation
index um but for me it it it was not
that it was manifesting our work in
shows and writing papers and writing
patents and creating a celebration
around the work and I never saw a a
distinction um you know between those
ways of being I also think that another
um kind of way of being or a modality of
being that I found helpful is um Victor
Frankl wrote this Incredible Book Men
search for meaning after the Holocaust
and he writes different people uh pursue
life for for for different reasons
According to Freud the the the goal of
of life is to find pleasure and and
according to Adler it's you know to find
power and um and for Victor Frankle it
was about finding
meaning and when you let go of the
titles and the disciplines and the
boundaries and the expectations and the
perception you you are elevated to this
really
special yeah spiritual but definitely
very very creative plane where you you
can sort of start a new mhm uh look at
the world through the lens of a
bacterium or a robot or it or you know
or look at ecology through the lens of
chemistry and look at chemistry through
the lens of Robotics and look at
robotics through the lens of You Know M
microbial ecologies and so on and so
forth and and I feel that kind of
rebooting um not every 10 years but
every minute every breath m is very very
important for a creative life and for
for just maintaining this fresh mind to
reboot reboot to begin again with every
breath begin again and and that can be
confusing for some right for my team
members you know I I like to change my
mind it's who I am it's how I think it's
how I operate M do you want to
open um you know and and and they'll
come and and we found another technique
or another technology that's interesting
and we thought that you know that we
were working on this functionalized
fragrance but now there's another
opportunity and let's go there and to
me I would much rather you know live
life like if I had to pick sort of my
favorite Broadway show um to enter and
live through it would be into the woods
it's not a specific fairy tale it's not
you know the Sleeping Beauty or or or
Little Red Riding Hood um or Rapunzel
it's all of them it's sort of moving
into the forest and seeing this wand and
getting close and learning about that
and then moving to another wand and life
is really about tying all of
these little fairy tales together uh in
work and and also in life unafraid to
LEAP into the unknown unafraid to LEAP
into the unknown speaking of MIT you got
a tenure at MIT and then you
leaped to New York and start a new
company that with a vision that doesn't
spend a couple of years but centuries
I did it was my destiny to start a
company and and do I have mornings when
I wake up and I ask myself what the hell
am I doing yes I I have those mornings
what do you do with those mornings by
the way I embrace them and I I find
gratitude and I say to myself thank
goodness I I'm so lucky to you know to
have the the the ability to be
frustrated in this way mhm um so I
really really embrace
these frustrations and I and I
I I take them I wrap them in a bubble
and I look at it you know on the outside
of my my uh um aware mind um and and I
laugh at them I smile at
them